[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i have no apologies
um robbie has indicated he has to leave
at six
and uh
me are leaving early at ten to six yeah
thank you wendy
someone well the rest of us will be here
until about midnight
now we won't uh no apologies no
any conflicts of interest thank you nan
confirmation of minutes from october
somebody like to move wendy moves robbie
seconds
i'll put those for recommendation all
those in favor say aye
thank you any matters arising from them
no everybody happy thank you we move on
to item five deputations
um we're reversing the order here are we
but um richard's got to get away so
we're doing
5.2 ahead of 5.1 gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon um i
won't dwell too long because most of you
already know richard lindsey who's chair
of rsl consulting
richards basically updated our plan for
our sports facilities plan which was
done originally for the last
ltp um so rich is going to talk through
that today
plus also he's updated the sioux
sutherland report around the
pegasus ravenswood northwood end
community facility provision
um so richard's also going to be talking
through that as well
so just mindful of time so i'll hand
straight over to you sir thanks grant
curet coach um i'm going to race through
the
sports facility plan uh in about 10
minutes
and then spend the second 10 minutes on
the pegasus wooden
ravenswood study so hopefully this thing
will work for me
which way do i point it just press that
one
i can probably just talk to this anyway
so um we don't really need a powerpoint
but
um oh sorry yeah
yeah how's that is it a little bit
better okay
um i'll just
essentially uh the 2020
sports facility plan is a update and
refresh of a document developed in 2017
to look at the issues and opportunities
around sport
and well sport facilities in the wymac
my summary of that oh it is
up there now my short version is
the the waimakariri district is well
served
with uh sporting facilities uh and
uh the key focus uh should be on
retaining
uh and enhancing the level of service of
a lot of those facilities
so in the report uh we've we've outlined
uh discussions with stakeholders and
clubs
trying to understand needs etc
i'll just flip to a graph
this this graph here um shows the
the purple line at the top uh relates to
the
axis on the right which is the why make
it early population
and the growth and the other three lines
are
scenarios of sports club membership and
i do this to look at what proportion of
people
uh in the wymac are participating in
sports clubs
and the currently most sports clubs are
reporting to us
that membership is relatively stable and
i say relatively stable some are
up a few some are down a few but
relatively stable
uh the exceptions being uh trampolining
report
significant growth year on year through
participations through the door not
membership
and rugby league in the survey have
reported an increase of
some somewhere in the vicinity of 40 odd
people um
you have to remember this is
self-reporting so um you know we have to
take people
uh on their word now these three
scenarios the the blue line
shows the the membership of people
involved in sports clubs uh staying
relatively static
and i guess that shows a picture the
proportion of people involved in sports
clubs
over a lengthy period of time uh is
is declining and i don't like saying
that because i'm involved in sport but
the reality is
there is a decline in a number of
traditional sporting codes
that said there is an increase in some
other sporting codes
but overall it's relatively stable
so what does this mean it means that we
need to look at
other ways of catering for people as
well so
maintaining the level of service that we
have across a number of codes
but also looking at what other
activities are people participating in
and then we look at the demographics of
the wymac and we look at the population
growth
and we also look at the aging population
and the wimac and what which activities
do the elderly or older people want to
participate
in over time because all the research
shows that
once you have more discretionary time
you try to seek out
things such as you know reducing your
golf handicap or
getting better at croquet or golf or
other activities
[Music]
but so that's that's just a useful bit
of information i'll just
cut to the chase we it was out of scope
of the report but we thought it was
really important to let people know that
a number of people participate in what
we call active
informal activities
far more than what they participate in
sports so
a challenge we were putting out in the
plan is how can we ensure we uh
we provide for people in in the
waimakariri
simple things like additional
pickup basketball courts more and more
opportunities for people to walk and
cycle we know that walking
is the largest form of physical activity
in the country by a long way but also
when we're developing our sporting
facilities ensuring that
when they're developed they meet the
needs of our older audience as well
so they are warm they're heated
acoustically they're acceptable so they
can
spectate and watch grandchildren
etcetera so making uh
facilities more accessible for people is
is something
to to look at going forward
so some key uh recommendations i
mentioned before
that you've got a strong base of
sporting facilities
there are no significant asset gaps and
clearly the main power stadium is
filling one of those gaps which
will open next year population
alone population growth alone will not
increase participation levels based on
what we know from the past
so sports are going to need to do
something different to increase
the number of people participating in
sport and recreation
and increasing the quality of sports
fields and facilities uh is something we
think
the wymac district needs to focus on
we've put a recommendation in the report
about ensuring there is some capital
to enhance main power oval when it opens
and if you think about any building
that's generally
constructed in new zealand there is a
bit of tweaking required
once it's open we're not talking huge
numbers we're just talking
around the edges to enhance it and make
sure that people use it as much as
possible
closely monitor the court we're all
we're getting feedback from
some of the ball codes that it's going
to be at peak
use as soon as it opens my
challenge to the sector is we still need
to take a network approach
to indoor courts we've still got a large
number of school courts
that can be used etc so some towns and
cities look at a rotation type system
where you get to play on the top courts
every second or third week and then
you're rotated to others so
we need to be really careful that we
don't over capitalize so
monitor that use monitor the use of the
network of
courts and then make a decision so in my
language let's take a breath
let's enjoy the indoor stadium when it
opens
but don't rush to the next stage
happy to take yep yep um
as an example badminton has lastly
disappeared from waimakariri
um how do we stop the really popular
sports that are there now like
basketball
not just booking out the indoor cook
completely
when there are sports we have to
re-establish in the district
it's a really good question and i guess
the the network of
facilities there will be surplus space
in other
halls that they will be able to
capitalise on
other towns and cities around the
country look
at apportioning a percentage of time to
minority sports
but that's really a management issue
that will be dealt with through the
north canterbury sport and wreck trust
through the north canterbury sport and
wreck trust because that was going to be
my question so who's going to put
together these drawers
and book the ohoka school hall
and the south brook new knife hall et
cetera
yep who's going to do that yeah so
that's the the
decision of the north canterbury sport
and rick trust with the sporting codes
so when they can use cold stream and
when they'll need to use other venues
there are a few more recommendations in
the report there's nothing uh
significant from a capital perspective
except you need to allow for
replacement or renewal of the artificial
turfs in the next 10 years so that's
that's in the report i'm very mindful of
time uh
so i'm going to go on to the next report
now and and if we've got time in the end
i can
um ask you know answer any any questions
oh robbie in
a report later on there's a 50 000
submission for lights at mandeville
i'm sitting there wondering we've got
kendall football not
currently paying their bills why are we
not pushing off
people who might use mandeville to
kindle which is you know less than 10
minutes away
yep um yeah good question uh
robbie um we've had a look at some other
sports that might be able to utilize
kindle
um we're gonna have to do a lot more
work with some of those
uh codes and certainly with football as
well they've had another change in their
committee so their chair and treasurer
that we've been working with for the
past year have both stood down
so look that club has had um just change
upon change so it's it's
it's a problem for us because obviously
the modeling for the
artificial turf at kindle park was based
on them paying us and paying back into
the depreciation fund
that's just simply not occurring which
is a real problem in terms of then going
to be able to fund the renewal of the
of the artificial turf in terms of
moving some of the other sports
rugby and rugby league have been a
little bit uh reluctant
um some of those sports that would
utilize lights there
the irb accreditation has become really
difficult for us in terms of
the playability of the artificial turf
they could potentially train there
if they wanted to certainly some of the
social teams could train there and kids
could train there
so there is definitely more
conversations needed around that to try
and push rugby that way
and i think if if i may briefly just say
something that myself and richard have
spoken about
one of the reasons that we're seeing
some of the edge sports kind of now
edging out some of the more traditional
sports is because they're willing to
um offer a different product
and when i say product they're offering
a thursday night comp or they're
offering a friday night comp
it's not just your traditional saturday
and sunday so
they're actually starting to see that
they're mopping up some of the people
who otherwise want to keep their
weekends free
and we're starting to see that across
the across the parks with with some of
the sports as well
so yeah i just made a final comment
around active recreation and ensuring
there are opportunities in the wymax so
i'll
quickly go on to the pegasus ravenswood
community facilities
needs and options report so this report
was
commissioned to review the sioux
southern report of 2018-19
with a purpose an independent assessment
of the need for additional community
facilities
in the district to primarily service uh
pegasus
woody and ravenswood communities and i
guess my language around
what end and ravenswood is probably more
around
what in generally once they're combined
i think
they're going to become a town in their
own right
so just looking at this report
i'd just like to acknowledge the people
from the pegasus community centre here
have provided great information
so there are there's previously adopted
levels of service that council signed
off
in a meeting i think it's the 18th of
january 2018 which says that
the council is going to provide library
services for urban populations of 10
000 people or more and community meeting
spaces for communities with a population
of 2500 or more
so i use that as a premise for our
assessment
the pegasus community center first is
currently provides for a range of user
groups so
you know there's an identified need
there it's operating
there's two lease spaces both due to
expire
june 2025 uh the total uh operating
expenditure is approximately 70 or 71
000.
it's in the report any community
facility developed in
we think there's an opportunity to
combine it with the
current studies that the council is
doing around youth activity
area that would make sense to have some
sort of synergy there
and i personally believe it was next to
the lake
uh and the lake uh was a lake
then there would be opportunities for
additional events to occur
uh in the wymac and particularly
um you know different lake user groups
etc accessing that space
so we've we've identified that
a space required in pegasus
approximately 385
but that that would change over over a
design period
um up or down whatever but a preliminary
estimate of capital costs for that type
of facility would be
in the vicinity of 2.12 i think the
report says 2.5
excluding land fit out professional fees
and we looked at the locations uh that
were
assessed for the youth activity area
around the center of pegasus
and we felt that 70 motu ki was
uh the most ideally located uh there
were another couple of sites there as
well
remembering this this is a draft report
and we're we're still
sort of looking at that in a bit more
detail
has anyone got any questions about the
pegasus community center before i go on
to the uh
the other wider community library slash
[Music]
community
sorry i'm not particularly spatial can
you give us an idea of what 385
square meters means like perhaps in
comparison to say the wooding community
centre do you know that facility
yeah well i as an example
a netball court if you're wanting some
spatial
uh that's uh 32.5 meters or 15.25 that's
about
450 square meters yep
yeah and it would include a larger
function space
uh some smaller meeting spaces but but
fairly functional
and we're saying it doesn't need to be
large because you would access larger
facilities elsewhere in the district
right so you would go to the likes of
this town hall or larger meeting spaces
for
those types of activities
similar question actually so the size of
the current facility
that we've got at least around that sort
of size is that i think
it's approximate yeah yeah thank you
slightly slightly it's 300 plus storage
so the next part of the study is we
looked at the level of service around
libraries and the population stats
show that the ten thousand magical ten
thousand
people mark will arrive
somewhere around twenty forty uh based
on stats we were provided by the council
and i've got a plus or minus there
because there are only rejections
we don't know sometimes things grow
quicker
but the important thing here is it's
still a wee way away
and from a library perspective things
can change quite a lot in 20 years
in fact the best way to think about that
is go back 20 years
and look what a library was like i'm
sure it was a lot different to what it
is now
so we need to think and be mindful of
that in our our planning
so i guess from our perspective it's
important to secure land
for these types of assets early
so you've then got the option if you
don't secure land and i guess i can
also speak for another report that's
coming up later on around aquatic
facilities
if you're going to develop these
facilities in the future
you need to land bank now so then you've
got some options
uh in the future
for the community library we we looked
at several
options around how that could be met
this is a larger space the
recommendation was around 750 square
meters
and you could lease a commercial
building if it was built
that's the 20 minutes
you could lease purchase land and build
or you could use
existing wymac district council sites
and we looked at a few of those as well
we once again think that there's
synergies in creating
this type of space adjacent to other
community facilities it's an
absolute no-brainer in terms of shared
services
car parking etc and potentially
reception
and there are some significant
dependencies around this
project the wooden bypass i believe will
hopefully change the nature of central
wood end and turn it back into a hamlet
slash village
and people will become feel comfortable
walking around the area a lot more etc
and so it could be a really nice
community space
preliminary capital estimate based on
the 750 square meters
4.8 to 6 million
so that's my 20 minutes
great merry christmas
great
ladies and gentlemen councillors and
committee members
thank you for the opportunity for us to
address you about the function
and the future of the main shed i'll
start with a brief history
the kai poi main shed grew out of the
need for a place for men to get together
to support each other
and the kaiapoi community after the
destructive earthquakes of
2010 and 2011.
initial gatherings were informal and
held in the garage and workshop of one
of our early members
an engineer as the group grew this could
not be sustained and sponsorship and a
site were found
our shed is on the grounds of sutton's
the old patients in nicholson factory
and they also provide us with our power
so it's a lovely sponsorship
sutton's australia has a strong link
with men's sheds
and organizations in australia sierra
donated a double garage but when the
members arrived to move the building it
had disappeared
purloined by somebody else however
another building was found
and early in 2014 a three-bay garage
was moved from cass street to the dale
street side of sutton's
the shed was lined insulated wired
including three-phase
power installed painted and prepared for
the grand opening on the 15th of july
2014. an extension to house a compressor
dust extraction system wood turning
lathes a veranda has been added to the
north side the shed
two containers were added to house the
metal workshop and the paint shop
and the timber store the two containers
were subsequently covered by a permanent
roof
and a space between enclosed to become a
dedicated paint shop
so what do we do well the main shed are
a mixed bunch the movement started in
australia
where there are currently over 900 sheds
it is now in the uk
ireland usa canada finland and greece
here in new zealand there are 118 sheds
and 30 in canterbury
some shares started as coffin clubs
there are nurseries
one is restoring a historic building
some are mainly woodworking
many have metal workshop some do
electronics
and in ash burton they build 3d printers
some like kaipoy are open a couple of
days a week
and some are open every day the shed
is what its members want it to be
in kaiapoi we do a lot of woodwork
mainly for the community
there is scope for the members to do
their own work although many have a good
workshop at home
and only bring work to the shed to have
access to specialized
or precision tools in the last three
years we have built
flat pack avery's for doc large picnic
tables for several schools
these have seating all the way around
build a market stand for a country
school
theater flats for the local high school
made the
daffodils for kaiapoi which you've all
seen
computer trolleys for a local school
grave crosses for a church cemetery and
for the rsa
frames for the coyote food forest cat
enclosures
converting patios to catios
raised garden beds shade houses half
side
road signs for a play centre to teach
children road safety
disability access ramps a beehive
giant connect four gender and coits
games
standard and disability access picnic
tables for the council
coffins chocolate wheel for the batted
woman's trust
refurbished beds for a local charity
rehousing families
that come through the battered woman's
trust large
outdoor toy boxes for low place local
play centers
shared for ride on mower teaching aids
shelves
mud kitchens and outdoor resources for
local preschools and kindergartens
rabbit jumps for the local bunny
fanciers and in case you don't believe
me
there is a rabbit olympics
they have serious meetings where you've
seen the dogs do the
dog show this is with rabbits
hurdles obstacles
you may well say and more coffins
so on top of this there are many
many small repair jobs from refurbishing
garden bench seats
of which you've done half a dozen to
date repairing fences changing light
bulbs
small jobs for the rsa and the list goes
on
each job is handled in a professional
way with a job sheet containing job
details and client details
and these job sheets this is two years
worth
okay so we've done a fair amount of work
but the best thing about our shed and i
have to emphasize this
our shed we come to together two
mornings a week
to spend three or four hours in a stage
in a state of
managed chaos to work on community
projects
enjoy each other's company maintain a
social network
and do what blokes enjoy doing
and do best working collaboratively on
projects in a non-competitive
environment
we only want two mornings a week no more
and we go happy as
we don't ask for more and nor do our
partners
so the men their families and the wider
community the shared is a source of
social connection
great for mental health and support and
a huge source of practical skills that
the community
can tap into and benefit from
in the last three years the membership
has grown quietly
and before the coronavirus lockdown
there would be up to 35
at a tuesday workshop and up to 25
on thursdays can you imagine 35 blokes
inside a space probably smaller than
this room
okay with all the power tools and all
the noise and all the hubbub
so it's pretty exciting at the moment
after the
lockdown the numbers are not quite the
same and not as steady
with about 24 to 30 members at both
tuesday and thursday workshop
last year there were 51 paid up members
and to date this year is 41.
at the moment when it is morning tea
time we have to clear space on a work
table
to put out cups this interferes with
workflow
all the administration work is also
carried out in the workshop
consequently we are now struggling with
space and the safety issues associated
with people getting in the way
our workshop is hard up against the
sutton's factory cafeteria
and one of the constraints connected
with occupying the site
is that when the factory staff are
having coffee or lunch break
we have to turn off all our noisy power
tools
as the staff has breaks and shifts this
results in three stoppages
in our morning work 9 30
10 o'clock and 11 45
we are currently preparing a clean space
with a serving hatch in the kitchen to
serve morning teas
space for administration files library
notice boards
and shelving to store products like toys
games and other items made by the men
this is a temporary solution to our
space problem but will enable us to
reconfigure the machines in the workshop
and make it a safer place to work
the other constraint that the space
limit puts on our growth
is that we are not able to add to the
diversity of activities
available to our members there are sheds
involved in running plant nurseries
some have well developed metal workshops
electronics wood turning painting
or like i've said before ashburton
building 3d printers
and although some sheets are open every
day and kaipoi
is open only two days a week this is how
the members want it
as this is how they manage to keep in
touch with each other
the shared is what the members want it
to be but if a member new or old wants
to branch out
we have no space to offer them it would
not even be possible to offer the shed
for other activities on other days
as the workshop is full with large tools
like saws and workbenches
all utilized for projects there is no
way to make space by storing the
projects
as there is nowhere to store them many
projects have to remain
under the veranda during the week when
members are not present
so the kaiapoi community hub the members
of the kaipa minshid
are of all ages although most are
retired
we have a range of skills including
teaching engineering
painting carpenter manager builder
butcher
electrician scientist cabinet maker
welder fitter and boat builder
the members are very sociable with a
streak of independence
a sprinkling of mischief and enjoy in
sharing their skills
in a workshop environment helping each
other and working for the benefit of the
community
while we are working to create a
temporary solution to the space
constraints that we operate under
this is a bridging step and we are very
keen to find a permanent location
with the capacity for growth and without
the constraint that we face at the
moment on the use of power tools
consequently working with the
waimakariri district council to
redevelop the red zone
as a space for community organizations
like the croakie club men's shed
and food security base is for the men
shed an
amazing opportunity to secure a
long-term
future even though this is realistically
about three years away we are fully
committed to the project
we are aware that operating without the
sponsorship provided by sutton's on
their factory site
will present new challenges however
there is nothing that the members have
not handled before
this is the beauty and advantage of the
collective experience of many mature and
senior members
we can do it all we've done it for the
kaipur community to have this resource
of skilled
and dedicated people concentrated under
one roof
able to assist in many ways including
mentoring
is an opportunity to be grasped and
developed
with this opportunity before us the
menshid will do what it can to help the
hub develop
and hope that the macarea district
council can see its way to support this
exciting community project
with the expertise of its staff and
support it all
financially thank you ladies and
gentlemen
comprehensive presentation there any
quickly any questions
remembering that we'll be discussing the
hub in the next item on the agenda
you've said it all sir thank you
[Applause]
i just wish i could bottle the madness
and bring it here
okay next up croakie
we have jam and brian
in supporters
mr chairman councillors and staff
i'm jan chisnall the president of the
kaiapoi croquet club
and today i'm supported by brian white
one of our members
brian's going to talk on the building
side of it and i'm going to talk on the
social
side so brian would you like to go
forward
thank you ladies and gentlemen the
existing facility at the end of
raven key has performed steering service
for over a hundred years
however the earthquakes of 10 years ago
caused problems which have only been
partially repaired
the current facility is undersized it's
past its best
and in need of repair and upgrade and
the club is continuing to soldier on
in the hope that something better will
eventuate
the proposed site on the corner of
courtney drive and
charter street is an excellent
greenfield site for the club's purposes
it's got a good location it's easy to
find and it's close to amenities
and the site is level and well drained
and ultimately will provide
good quality playing services and also
there's ample land
to allow for expansion over time and the
letter of intent from the council
from october set up the council offer
which is essentially
site works and boundary fencing council
services to the boundary
two operational full-sized irrigated
croquet lawns and fees and support for
resource and building consents
so the major effort by the club is the
buildings
which is a new clubhouse and an
equipment
come mower shed proposed designs
envisage that the
single level structure will be
residential style and fit in with the
location
it will be of sufficient size to cater
for the expanded
club membership in future years
and kitchen and amenities to enable
functions associated
with club activities and of course
fundraising
preliminary costings have been attained
for this work and
clearly fundraising will be required
which will involve on our part
club activities such as club fun days
twilight and corporate events
and public open days
also donations and grants from
established providers
interested in sport and community
well-being
and any shortfall will be covered by a
loan but the time
frame envisaged uh from obtaining the
green light from council
hopefully and relocating from
raven key to courtney drive is some
two to three years in that region
and that's ample time for the club to
perform its obligations
so the proposal now before council
provides an opportunity
for a new start which is what really
what we're looking for club members
accept that there are
challenges ahead there's a lot of hard
work
but are excited the prospect of new
facilities
which will improve the playing
experience materially assist the club to
grow
enable greater numbers to participate in
the game of croquet
and the social activity associated with
that
thank you very much
my turn the kyboy croquet club has
served as the people of kaiapoi
for about 115 years during that time it
has had membership
highs and lows going from eight members
to 29 at present with three pending
as a club we are aware of the
government's wish to include
well-being in all aspects of life
we're doing our best to incorporate this
into our croquet club
connectedness croquet is a game for all
ages
the very young the middle aged and the
elderly
is very kind to aging bones minimal
equipment is needed
soft shoes a sun hat a mallet a ball and
a hoop
and you're off to encourage new members
we lend mallets and give
free six free sessions we have open days
to show the community what croquet is
all about
and we gather up new members on those
days
giving our club is a team and together
we work as a team
both at the club and off the club i mean
away from club days
loud encouragement is given to those who
execute a good shot
quiet advice is given to those who are
struggling a little
members and their families give time to
keep our club going
by painting mowing cleaning hedge
trimming and general tasks about the
grounds
our grounds actually are a credit to the
club
being active croquet is a very active
game
it's stimulating both mentally and
physically
you need to be able to anticipate and
plan every move
it's a game game as i said before that's
gentle on aging limbs
age is not a barrier and our lawns are
available to members to use
at any time social connections
we encourage our team to participate in
inter club
and club competitions we meet together
each club day for afternoon tea
and for the occasional meal friendships
are made through club connections
social isolation is a concern but kai
poi keeps an eye on its members
phone calls a note or a visit is made to
those who are unwell
or have been absent for a while keep
learning
the team is kept informed of all
opportunities to further their croquet
skills
recently we had coaching in the
subtleties of the game
and another on the croquet new zealand
rules
this mean our team this means our team
is playing to exactly the same roles
as every other team in new zealand we
always bring away
new ideas when playing inter-club
competitions
health and safety our team is aware of
health and safety requirements
all hazards are labeled members wear
information regarding health
next of kin and so on on the reverse of
their name tags
we have a covert sign and available for
all who enter our club rooms
in conclusion croquet is a game for all
ages and is to be
encouraged equipment is loaned to new
players
social interaction plays a very
important role
fun laughter and friendly banter is
often heard from the players
physical movement is important as we age
and inter-club visiting forms important
social connections
we fulfill many of the well-being
suggestions and are more than just a
croquet club
our role in kaiapoi is very important in
keeping
people physically and mentally active
socially connected
and out of doctor's waiting rooms
recently i held a vote regarding the
future of the club
using chris brown's letter with the
options set out
and asked the team to vote on whether to
move or not
the vote was 99 4 with one dissension
some members are still concerned about
finances but the mayor spoke to us and
reassured us about this
we thank the mayor and councillors and
staff
he might give us a loan
we thought you're going to go to the
private loan
we thank the mayor councillors and staff
of the waimakariri district council for
their time
support and encouragement as we face an
exciting future
on our planned move to new facilities
thank you
jen thank you thank you both very much
for this i'm just wondering when
while you when you are preparing and
getting ready for your move
have you um talked to the wrangler ones
about how they
have set about doing their their grounds
and
how they're fundraised and all the rest
of it have you we have that's excellent
well done because
no good reinventing the wheel is it not
or not
thank you jan very nice to see you again
and brian um
just a question we've heard just from
the men's shed just previously and
looking at the locations they're kind of
the furthest away
you guys are in the middle and then the
food forest food
security place will be next to the
residential area
do you have any concerns about the noise
from women's shed
being at cocaine are you are your
members happy to allow as
another community activity um taking
place next to you
not at all worried all good um you know
if they if we could use different days
it's not really going to be a problem
actually sure thank
next door to you club exactly
thank you for inviting us everyone um
i'm steph i'm the manager
at satisfy food rescue and also a key
stakeholder in
the food secure north canterbury group
here i have one of our lovely trustees
ann barnes who's joining me today
and rachel thornton i'd like to
start by talking a little bit about
satisfy food rescue and what we do
we are currently rescuing food from six
supermarkets
across the district out to amberley
rangyura
kai poi mandeville we collect weekly
monday to friday each morning and as
part of those collections we
muster a team of volunteers that come
and help us with the work that we do
we've been operational since 2015
and started with one supermarket back in
2016.
we had a very small space as part of the
kaipoy community centre
and that space in itself would have been
around 25 to 30 square meters in size
and the volume of food that we were
processing
each morning was incredible
if you could see the space you would be
very surprised
the types of food that we're rescuing
are bread bakery produce
meat which is frozen dairy items
basically anything that is very close to
its used by data can't be sold in the
supermarkets we take it
it doesn't go to the pigs we get it to
humans and people who
are in need the space that we were in
was too small for us
prior to lockdown we were rescuing
around six to eight tons of food per
month
which is enormous creating many meals
for many families in the district
we were very fortunate as part of the
ministry for social development funding
that food secure north carolina be
secured
to be able to put some money aside for
two years rental in a larger space which
is around 240 square meters it's a
warehouse
with an office space at the front
post lockdown and during lockdown uh
volumes grew between um from six to
eight
tons per month up to 15 tonnes
and we were able to get that out through
our
stakeholders and recipient organizations
27 of which were coming to collect food
on a daily basis
we've moved into the new space and we
currently are still collecting
around on average 12 tons of food per
month so that the growth has been
sustained
and i believe there are a number of
factors and
that are contributing towards that the
um airtea food rescue
alliance which has been established this
year will be supporting food racial
organizations across new zealand
in addition the new zealand food network
are rescuing food across the country
and actually creating a south island hub
which will mean that we get more food
more regularly and we're already seeing
that coming in
by the pallet load each week which is i
think this week we're expecting about
four pallets that are coming just
directly from the new zealand food
network which is out with
of our usual collections
the um i think the other thing is that
businesses are more mindful
post um look down about the amount of
food that can easily go to waste
and the number of number of people that
do actually
need food in the district that don't
have food security
another interesting fact is that the
world food programme
food security won the nobel prize peace
prize in 2020
so i think looking to a community and
ensuring food security in the district
is
quite important
i'd just like to tell you a couple of
things about our
organisation the the volunteers that we
have around the bank of
40 of those we've got really high
volunteer retention
we feel that they are
an integral part of what we do we really
couldn't do the work that we do
without them and in addition the
organizations that we support with the
food
range from food banks across the
district to local schools
for the breakfast and lunch clubs to
community soup kitchens
to community lunch programs helping
reduce social isolation
and i think that's all from me at the
moment
oh you want me to write so we talk about
our volunteers because they're very
valuable
but um i've been yeah i've been part of
satisfy food rescue for nearly four
years i was their first employee
they secured funding for 10 hours a week
and that was coming up four years ago
now
i'm now one of a team of four people we
have a driver
who collects the food every day she
works 10 hours a week
we also have michelle our distributions
coordinator
so she works with the recipient
organizations making sure that we're
meeting their needs and that none of the
food that we give to them goes to waste
and in addition just recently we've
employed cameron crowley and he
is our operations coordinator who's in
our office for 25 hours a week making
sure
that we are um getting the food out to
where it needs to go
and that we are operationally sound
anything else then no
rachel is there anything else you want
me to add
so in terms of um i'll put my food
secure north canterbury hat on now
so in terms of the um the community
having kai poi and what it will mean for
satisfy
it will mean that we can collaborate
within our community to make sure that
we
are meeting the needs of those
organizations that need
the food so a lot of the
food banks and in addition um anyone
else in the in the community
like the um cowboy food forest
uh and all the other trusts that we're
going to be working with
that we can make sure that we are
meeting meeting the need really
it's i think the i'm sorry just one more
thing i think the
the realisation of this new biggest
space that we've got we've actually
almost
outgrown it and it's incredible to think
that we can jump from 30 square meters
to 240 square meters and suddenly
we're you know we actually need more
space but we really need
um somewhere that's fit for purpose i
think it's not the type of thing that
you can just go and find a facility that
that we can rent readily
so i think the the food sorry the
community hub in kai poi would
would probably take a huge box there
thank you thank you stephanie um just
clarifying with this
food source north canterbury you say
you've got to amberly
do you also go to oxford where all do
you does oxford
in terms of collecting food so we at the
moment delivering and collecting
so we don't deliver food but we do
community we do work with
the oxford community trust right and
we're doing some work with the oxford
lines they've recently planted
um through the food secure north
canterbury funding that we received
they planted an enormous amount of
potatoes and corn
that we've done our first harvest today
so we've got new potatoes that are going
out to all those organizations that we
support over the next um
really the coming months until they
stalk's been exhausted
right so really oxford really is
self-supporting itself basically
um well i i don't know i mean i believe
the food that we give to oxford is
valuable they come and collect from us
it's a fair distance to come and get
food so we're obviously um
providing them with much needed
additions to
to the food that they're already
securing so
very yeah thank you
lovely okay
oh good afternoon the purpose of this
report is to seek support from the
committee for the inclusion of 435
000 in funding in the long term plan for
the development of the kaipoy community
hub
this report essentially draws together
all the work staff have been doing over
the last year with the community groups
and the previous information presented
to the committee in august and october
and for this reason i'll take the report
as read
this afternoon we've heard from food
security north canterbury the kuiper
men's shed and the kaipoy croquet club
all have indicated their support for the
community hub and their willingness to
be part of this
all these groups in their own way
support the health and wellbeing of our
community
and i'd like to say thank you to them
for coming and presenting and for the
work and the effort they've put in
working with us over the last few months
in particular at the last meeting we
were asked to undertake some early
consultation with the neighbouring
residents near the community hub
and at the end of november we delivered
a consultation flyer to these properties
in the media area and posted the same
flyer to absentee owners
the flyer introduced the hub project and
asked for initial feedback
it also let residents know that rachel
and i would be available at the
community
sorry the christmas carnival in kaiapoi
to date we've received two pieces of
formal feedback
one in support of the hub and one in
opposition the feedback and opposition
would prefer to see the land area
redeveloped for residential land uses to
assist with the
housing shortage and provide some
additional rates for council
and the feedback and support commented
that every community needs a space to
connect and this builds on resilience
and well-being
at the carnival rachel and i spoke to
about 10 groups of residents throughout
the day
most wanted to understand more about the
project
we had one resident from wyber place who
was opposed
to the proposed hub unfortunately they
had moved in after the red zoning
process and were advised at the time of
purchase that there would be never any
building on any land in the area
and they really enjoyed their park
outlook unfortunately there was no
mitigating factors
um that would alleviate this opposition
however
the majority of the comments received
were seeking more information and were
in
um i won't there weren't joyous rapture
of support but there was an underlying
there was an underlying feeling of
support in general the three issues
raised and these are not unknown traffic
and parking so additional traffic coming
to courtney drive and where were the
vehicles going to park
security um that there was antisocial
behaviour occurring in the area
at the moment and that either the hub
would exacerbate this or be
a victim of that anti-social activity
and concerns and wanting to understand
what the buildings might look like
which is understandable from residential
neighbours in that area
all of we think that all of the above
can be addressed through the development
of a draft master plan and user
obligations and these we would intend to
take
out for consultation in the new year so
those residents could understand a
little bit more about
what we're looking at and what we're
thinking about and have some of the
input to that
we still have a few more days for
feedback to come in and we'll provide an
update on that in the new year
as stated the report the purpose of the
report to seek support for funding
it's noted that the 435 000 for the hub
is included in the current annual plan
50 000 for this year and 435 indicated
for next year it's also been included in
the draft long term plan for
consideration by council
next year as noted in the report
the inclusion of this funding in the
long term plan is expected to have 1.53
and 0.05
rating impact per property
as the report states we will keep
working with the hub groups that we've
seen today and bring the draft master
plan user obligations and the funding
strategy that rachel's developed through
for approval in the new year
should funding become available through
the long-term plan we can then move into
the detailed design
full consultation and consenting phases
of the project
and rachel and i are happy to answer any
questions you may have
firstly i just want to commend uh
michelle in the first instance because i
know you've been
working on this for quite some time
and i commend you on the development of
this it's really is a community
developed model
it's providing a need i think for that
well that's been well demonstrated
uh you know i don't have any uh issue at
all in this being considered in the long
term plan and the organizations that
have spoken all
have talked of the various needs that
they have it's kind of similar to
the model we developed some years ago at
northbrook studios and
see how that's been a really good
success
the croquet it's been a lot of work
going with our croquet club
over the years in considering even
options on their own site to mitigate
the effects of flooding
and other impacts and it's just it just
isn't really an
answer apart from moving from another or
building a giant bund
which is isn't really terribly practical
so i know that they have looked at all
options and really the only option
really is to look at moving
and then 115 years of age i think they
deserve
the opportunity for a new site so i'm in
full support of that
it's also an opportunity for that club
to to
build its membership and we look at what
rangiura croquet has done
through its new site new greens it now
has a very strong membership and i
understand
kyle boyce membership is growing so
i fully support that around
satisfied food rescue i think they've
built their case very well
and they've indicated the growth that
they have there of
i've had the opportunity to visit all
the various groups actually including
the men's shed
i went down before the election last
year and had a good look at what they
were doing
rengura invited me recently down to
their site they measured me up for a
coffin
actually uh i need to say there was a
very large one they required
but um i was quite um quite
surprised how industrious they are is as
is our
kaapoy means sheet and that all the
tasks that they're involved with that
they build
um and make including the daffodils that
go on the bridge and kaiapoi
there's a really real community aspect
behind
all these organizations so from my point
of view it's a no-brainer that this
should be
considered as part of our long-term plan
we've got to be careful what we say in
this process because
obviously we're subject to a process but
i
i personally think that the inclusion of
this
is something that our council should
consider strongly
as it comes into its long-term plan next
year it's an excellent use of the land
and and also the hubbing for those
organizations they as you can hear today
from the comments that have been made
those organizations look to be very
aligned and
i don't think there'll be any issue
there and i think michelle you've done
your due diligence michelle
is um sorry rachel as well as helping
out with the funding
and other aspects which will go on
behind it so the council including 435
thousands just to start really the other
organizations will need to get in behind
and fundraise
um for the additional activity but from
my point of view
it's an ideal location and a community
hub will help develop our community
further so
it carries my support
thank you again without preempting the
ltp process
um i'm seconding this i'll obviously
support it going through to it to that
stage and the mirrors use the the term
no-brainer and i'd also
it's a no-brainer as far as uh
everything's concerned um the
presentations were absolutely brilliant
i love the way the
word well-being was being brought in by
some of the
some of the groups this is today's
agenda is incredibly big
it is incredibly important as far as
positioning ourselves
not only for the near future but the
long-term future which is
was a bit grumpy to see such a large
agenda to be honest but
getting back on track well done
thank you mr chair i see this as
enhancing community well-being and um
i came to the realisation that all the
groups that have presented
have common goals really social
connection
fellowship companionship dealing with
social isolation so
i i think it's great and if we can all
work together
or the groups can work together i think
there can be great outcomes so
i'm in support of the recommendation
yeah yeah yeah whatever so i'll put um
a2 f for adoption orders in favor say
aye
against kerry thank you
thank you everybody you're all welcome
to stay for the rest of the meeting if
that is your
wish for the a warm hot afternoon
otherwise you are welcome to go
thank you for hearing from us thank you
for your help
i'll try not to forget right of reply
again
excuse me can i just make a wee note so
we can change it
it's actually a to k what did i say
a to e i think you mean
oh yes yes yes yes yes yes gotcha
that's what we'll just just we just need
to change the
right we're up to where are we 6.2
sam
youth development report
sam and helper little elf you brought
your little elf along
okay hello everyone great to be here um
my name's sam redmond youth development
facilitator um
and uh here is uh nathan croft he's one
of our youth development interns
who has been helping us out with um with
a project that you'll hear about
very soon nathan is a master's student
from the university of canterbury
and came to us through the pace program
at
uc
so don't want to take up a huge amount
of time here so i
will take the two reports as read but by
way of a quick
summary over the last year and a half
through the
pace program we've had two masters
student interns join us in the community
team for a few months at a time
those internships focused on oh and
sorry i will
oh yeah thanks there
um at the internships focused on two
related areas youth spaces and youth
activities
and resulted in the two reports that you
will have seen
those two specific issues were
identified because despite
the important and ongoing work done by
youth action groups over the last 10
years
youth spaces and events are still
consistently identified as areas of
challenge
for our district nathan was our first
intern he joined us in late 2019
and he produced the youth spaces report
and he is just going to briefly tell you
a little bit about the two reports
thanks nathan so the internships
involved
extensive consultation with young people
and community stakeholders
as well as research into existing local
regional national
international and international ideas
and solutions
i spent a number of weeks meeting and
talking with stakeholders from the youth
services network to identify areas of
need
within the community
areas of need from from the community's
perspective i also researched a number
of
different youth space models from around
the country and overseas
subhan the other intern developed and
distributed a survey which received 196
submissions from young people across the
district in relation to youth activities
both reports while having different
focuses identified some similar areas of
need
and opportunity including transportation
being a barrier for many young people
difficulty gaining employment due to
lack of experience and skills
and the need for access to services
regarding mental health and well-being
the two reports also offer some
recommendations for next steps
which include the development of a youth
centre or centers
establishment of a network of
youth-friendly spaces incorporating the
libraries and skate parks
provision of transportation for young
people
programs that develop young people's
skills talents and experience
and initiatives that give young people a
place to belong get connected and get
access to the services they need
another key outcome which should be
mentioned is the work done in gathering
information for an online direct
directory of youth services
opportunities and places which i put
together as plasma as part of my
internship
thanks nathan so moving swiftly on
so what are our next steps i've just got
a few that i'll quickly run through
the first of these following on from the
reports is to present the reports to the
youth services network
which will be as part of a youth forum
we really think it's vital that our
community be provided with good
information to make informed decisions
about their work um and we don't want
that work to be lost so
this will be a priority in 2021
following on from what nathan said the
development of an online directory
this is an exciting piece of work which
we're really keen to progress
we want this to be a useful tool for
both youth organizations and for young
people themselves to find information
about what's going on for young people
in the district in terms of events
opportunities places to hang out
it does need to be some careful
consideration around the best way to
implement this
whether it's a phone app a website or
some other form
i mentioned this already but a youth
forum will be another
objective uh the youth forum will
present the reports the survey results
the research undertaken over the last
year and a half and it will ask
stakeholders to consider
what objectives should be included as
part of a youth-friendly community plan
which is uh the final point here the
creation of a youth-friendly community
plan
drawing on everything that's gone before
bringing it all together into some
tangible objectives with some concrete
goals
and then working with the network and
the broader community to implement them
to so to see some action taken
and there's potential that there may be
another youth internship which will work
with the university
as part of that uh that whole piece of
work
um could we move on to the next slide
and the one next sorry so i just want to
take
this opportunity to present a concept
which has been floating around in my
head for about a year
which i think has some potential as we
look forward especially
as we look at writing the youth friendly
communities plan
as we've been consulting with the
community and as we've had discussions
with stakeholders as needs and issues
have been identified
this is a concept that has been uh work
working i guess bubbling away in my mind
so i'll just quickly run through it
keeping in mind that it is
relatively high level it doesn't delve
into details it hasn't yet been
presented to the youth network
but a model like this or similar to this
could provide a good framework to
address
many of the identified needs that we're
seeing in our district
so really quickly uh satellite centers
so potentially a center in each town
whatever that looks like
it may not look like a traditional youth
center that you're picturing in your
mind maybe it's an existing space maybe
it's a coffee shop that has a youth
night
or a community center that's already
existing
like i said use of existing locations a
notice board
whether that's physical or online
advertising overcoming
activity across the district
and youth friendly spaces so the
satellite centers are obviously
represented by the the four bubbles
there
the youth friendly spaces are
represented by the white bubbles
which could be a network of official
youth-friendly spaces across the
district
endorsed by waimakariri youth spaces and
these could be skate parks coffee shops
parks etc with endorsed spaces regularly
being used
and promoted as part of whatever the
program is
next slide please so a strong network
which is obviously
shown by the lines there with a shared
program of events initiatives workshops
and training
transportation this is a key one it's
come up time and time again
um with it within our consultations
with so having having the transportation
to connect our young people
and a consistent brand why mercury why
my career youth spaces are an
alternative
which creates a recognizable identity
and i think this last point there really
sums up a lot of what we're saying here
something that will connect the young
people of the district through a network
of spaces places
and events
just to put some of that into
perspective
a couple of fictional scenarios to
consider
is 14 lives in oxford with his parents
and siblings
it's friday night he doesn't have much
to do so he and a couple of friends jump
into a specially organized youth van
which takes them into caipor where a
youth movie night is taking place at the
community center they have a great time
hanging out having fun and the community
youth workers are super cool
potential as a potential scenario that
we could see happening
lid year 17 she also attends the movie
night on a friday and she notices
there's a coffee van run entirely by
young people
she's been looking for a job but she's
been told time and time again she
doesn't have the required experience
she signs up to help and by this time
next month she's serving coffee and hot
chocolates gaining valuable experience
and she also starts getting involved
with community events which the coffee
van attends
grace is 13 and has been struggling
recently with anxiety and depression
she went to see the school counselors
but they're super busy right now she's
not sure what to do
the school youth workers let her know
about an event happening down at the
youth center this week and she decides
it could be fun
while there she notices that the youth
centre also has counsellors and she puts
her name down for a free appointment
sammy is a 15 year old high school
student who finishes school at 3 20 p.m
and heads down high street to hang out
with her friends they go to a local
youth friendly coffee shop where in the
hour after school they can get two
dollar coffees and hot chocolates
they hang out for a couple of hours in a
safe youth-friendly space
so i think we can all agree that it
would be fantastic to see stories like
this becoming more commonplace in our
district
issues of social isolation employment
well-being belonging
community connection our issues which we
see coming up regularly
i do want to stress that there is good
work already being done
done in these areas but there are still
gaps barriers
and opportunities this could be a way of
addressing
some needs and issues or perhaps there's
another way but the hope is that out of
the youth friendly communities plan
we will see some action taking place and
some positive outcomes like this
whatever form
they might take final thoughts
um again don't want to take up too much
of your time but
um this is something that i try and
remind myself about
often when we talk about youth
development the young people of our
district are the main thing
as our youth strategy says we want to
see young people engaged and connected
valued and supported and given the
opportunity to grow
develop and get excited about their
future
our job now in collaboration with the
community is to translate
the work that we've done into tangible
actions that will make a difference for
our young people
i'm really looking forward to that
challenge and i think our community is
up for it too
so thank you for your time and if there
are any questions
we would be happy to take them
just a question from me having spoken to
a mother
yesterday that she has a daughter that's
visually impaired and and and has
actually become
really um
yes and and is not coping
and she's just really struggling about
how she can get her daughter
out into the into this youth spaces and
to try and develop her more
yeah question please that's that's it's
a hard one and i think
um with the added difficulty of being
visually impaired that that does add to
it but we and i've seen
a lot of young people i think social
isolation
often we don't think about young people
but there are young people out there who
um are not connected um part of that
is social media that part of that is um
just not having the confidence to step
out and i think
you know there are there are uh programs
out there that have
that are happening in our community some
really great vibrant youth groups and
other community activities and but i
think
one of the big issues and i think this
is where the directory that we've been
talking about comes into play is
actually getting that information
out into people's hands making sure
young people know what is
what is on offer um but yeah there are
gaps and the
there are opportunities i think for the
for future development
and that's where i think perhaps there
is a gap at the moment that needs to
probably be fulfilled
okay
thank you guys good presentation
thanks
please i think bee doesn't really quite
read correctly so
i've wondered what the tenses are notes
staff presented um to the community and
recreation committee
the rest says and request staff to
present the findings and reports to the
youth council
and why youth committees and the rest
deserts
absolutely
just briefly excellent report um sam
really enjoyed the findings thank you to
the interns for
to both of you for the work that you've
have collected here
i think you're right sam um the
propositions you stated at the end were
probably really ideal solutions so if we
can get to that point that'll be
excellent
i just i wanted to make sure that it
gets to y
youth into the youth council because
obviously they are our
key constituents in this case and also
our key partners
in in constructs of our own organisation
so
i know you will would have anyway but i
just think it's important that our
council
suggests that that go is the pro a place
in which that goes
i just like uh seeing you to commend you
for all your efforts sam i
you know nikki uh kirsten and myself are
on the youth council
we know how much work you put in and how
respected you are
by our young people for the way in which
you
take them on that journey so just to say
thank you and happy christmas
thank you thanks very much thank you sam
and thank you very much for all the work
you've done um i just looking at
when i first came onto council i was on
the youth
and and seeing the difference you know
how how you've involved and growing
and and taking the children along with
you which is wonderful
and i really and this is just the
beginning of adding more to it and i've
given you perhaps something to think
about as well
and i really appreciate you the work
you're doing thank you
my two cents worth in here great report
sam and
i love the um the concrete cool ideas
that you've gathered from
all over the place and put into this
report and i
am looking forward to seeing how our
youth council receives them
and seeing what we can hopefully put
into action
in the next year so hats off to you both
thank you
thank you okay without any further ado
let's put 6.2 for
adoption a 2d all um all those in favor
say i'm
against carrie thank you moving on
six point thank you three thanks guys
cheers tessa
age friendly report
six point nine perfect for pegasus yeah
guys thinking of that will go next
up
okay right and then bring it and then
bring that in
quick good afternoon
and um i'd like to welcome joanne
gumbrell who is the chair of the age
friendly advisory group who has come to
to join us and to support madeleine with
the great work that she's done in
preparing the progress report so
um this report
details key activity in relation to the
delivery of the age-friendly waimakariri
plan
over the past six months and the
intention is that we
come back to the community and
recreation committee
every six months just with an update as
to how the plan is progressing
this this report focuses on four key
areas that are detailed in the progress
report
those being community support and
health services available to older
people in the district
respect and social inclusion
communication
and information and social participation
that is making sure that older people
are
able to participate in the life of the
community
have their voice heard and be involved
some of this work sits under business as
usual
and when the plan was developed
it was highlighted that the plan was
intended to be something of a gap
analysis
and an opportunity analysis to
ensure that the great stuff that's
already
happening in our community to make sure
that older people are included empowered
and formed
continued but that it could be
built on so this report
particularly summarizes key activities
that are either new are complete
have been completed over the past six
months or are still outstanding
and in terms of outstanding activities
it is likely that they will be delivered
on in the next period or two
you will see the full progress report
and an
overview of the age friendly model
attached to
my report and i ask that the committee
notes the work of the age friendly
facilitator madeleine burden
and the age-friendly advisory group and
really championing
the cause of quality lives for our older
people in the district
and particularly the role that they
played over the covert 19
event in making sure that older people
had access to information and support
that they needed
um we i will take the report as read
and madeleine is happy to answer any
questions that you might have
as in uh you have explained it all very
competently here
no questions nikki
as always i love your work ladies um
i noticed on page 98 one of the
priorities you talked about continued
promotion and facilitation of mature
driver refresher training which is
outstanding but
is back on track um i'd love more
information about that
okay so there's age consume actually
provide that
in our district um they've had some
staff uh
leave before and after covert there's
three new staff
who've actually connected us with us and
i asked
um i think it's liz gray recently so she
said they'll be
kicking back in early next year and
sorry and how do you
how do you um connect with her
so the the programs are developed and
advertised
so people need to enroll and they engage
the local services in our area so we'll
put it in chatter but i can add you into
an email
uh about that if um uh that would be
great yes
um i'm obviously not asking for myself
but but my mother has my mother arrived
here
well about 14 years ago and she got her
license and passed her test and
got all of that but she's never really
been confident enough to drive here
and i think that something like that
would be just what the doctor ordered so
so sorry i was asking purely out of
personal interest
but thank you thank you
for the questions okay
we only got to remove a to receive the
report
sorry no they're all notes
well we we still receive them okay
receive in three notes um
um wendy thank you very much very much
appreciate being
joanne as well thank you very much for
all the hard work that's been done
um appreciate the effort that we've
put on to us in particular 19 that has
changed things
and it's making us more aware of just
what um
making us more aware of just what is
required in our community and it's still
bubbling up too so
i just like to say thank you very much
and we have got
another year of um real serious thinking
about
and while i'm just about this i'd just
like to mention yvonne palmer
that was our coordinator for the
um the driver training um
evon became extremely ill last year and
she's had to give it away now
so hopefully um i think there's another
one starting very shortly but
and and that was all done through road
safety so
thank you
simply that um as always
i receive your report with admiration
and gratitude
well done ladies and um keep up the good
work
thank you it's a privilege to do the
work
no any other speakers everyone happy
windy rate of replay
thank you i'll put 6.3 for adoption then
stop
grinning at me mr mayor um call us in
favor say all right against carrie
6.4 library
thank you it's a very jovial meeting i
have to say there's a lot of laughter
slider unsettling um
we could do laughing kia ora koto so the
purpose of my report is
to share and discuss
any of the potential solutions that were
identified to a
address the space issues at rangiora
library
address the end-of-life status of the
district library self-issue kiosk
and socialize the recommendation to
abolish
finding our youngest people in the
district for having overdue library
books
and library items i should say i'll take
it as the report is largely read
as this is my first time reporting in
this sort of ltp
um please correct me if i'm doing
anything wrong
but i would like to um
share a little bit of local information
pertaining to the four points
that we've addre that we've noted in the
report
so 4.2 addresses
the need for the library's self-issue
kiosks
to be replaced or improved
um i'd like to just to share with you
some thinking that went on behind this
report so there is significant
technological changes happening
in the library self-issue kiosk
environment
in the next five to seven years um
zero to five years we can realistically
anticipate that the self-issue machine
as we know it will not change
significantly
in the five to ten year landscape it is
probable
that people in our community
predominantly younger people will be
using an
app on their cell phones that they can
issue their own books
i wanted to socialize that that's been
accept that is being explored
and we are current with that thinking
but given our local
our use of the consortia apn k for our
library services
they are not in the space to take on
board the app
service that is available in some
libraries
overseas so that that has been
considered
i'd also like to share that
investigation has happened
into a basic upgrade of the software
inside of the kiosks we are
running on a version four which is a bit
like an
iphone three or four generations ago
and as we know with apple and major
phone providers
the ability to replace the components
becomes more and more difficult
this afternoon in preparation for the
meeting i did contact the vendor and say
an
anticipation of a of a quirky question
around the technology of who has come to
worse could
we survive with an internal upgrade of
those machines
he said for now it is possible and i'm
wanting to disclose that publicly
but the investment would be a short-term
solution to a
what is essentially a long-term
challenge for us as a district library
service
i anticipate that by upgrading the
kiosks
it would take us from next year to
probably six
seven years from now when the app-based
technology would be more
dominant and we would be re-evaluating
the library
self-service options again
so that's just some of the background
thinking that went it was not recorded
in that report otherwise it would have
been a novel
and then thinking about points
4.4 and 4.5
which really address the space issues
at rangiora library i'd like to
publish state publicly that i
acknowledge and appreciate the reasons
for the deferral
of the rangiora library extension
we accept that the library as it is at
the moment has actually outgrown its
space as of 2014.
um district population growth and use of
the library is very different
to what it was 10 years ago as
richard talked about in his presentation
it's widely acknowledged that libraries
are more about books
than um than than they were
and now that we have the nz lpp the new
zealand library's partnership two
positions
we are about a lot more about learning
as well i'd like to just share some good
news that we received this morning we
have been proud recipients of a
third full-time secondment for the nz
lpp
that will take we'll start recruiting in
january for that so that's three
full-time positions until the end of
june 2022.
um i get got what i asked one of my team
to grab some data on active library
users at the moment
so within the district we have
approximately 35 000 members
the last full non-covered year
so we're looking at july 2018 to end of
june 2019
we had just on 14 000 active library
users
in the last six months we have had just
on 11
000 active library users
as we're offering more services beyond
the book we're not taking away from the
book it's the end and end
our use the use of our services and our
spaces is at a premium
last thursday night we hosted a book
launch at
hanifakayapui civic center we had five
assist dogs
nearly 50 members from the community and
we had an
amazing night launching a locally
produced book about assist
dogs i'd like to just
read you what one of my team was shared
about the use of the library space
by two ladies who have been library
users for a very long time
years ago they told us that libraries
would be gone from our communities
as they would be outdated and no longer
needed now that we have
everything online but look what is
happening here this evening
who would have thought that we could
have dogs and so much joy in our library
she went on to say how she loves the
atmosphere in our libraries
how she can feel she can just pop in a
time
when she simply needs a space to be in
without
any pressure to buy anything she also
said how amazing the staff are so
friendly
and helpful last night we hosted the
rangiora volunteers
christmas event and at the end of the
night we were reassembling the library
and i've known for a long time that the
shelving at rangiora
is not fit for purpose but it took
five staff to move a double bay of books
and to be perfectly honest some of our
staff would not physically be able to do
that
in libraries at kaiapoi i can move a
double bay
of books on my own that's how heavy
and restrictive the things are at the
shelving is at
rangiora so i'm just putting that into
context
are there any questions about those bits
i'll move on to fine sorry
i was just going to ask you paula did
you have any priorities in
clause 5.1 um we're talking about the
library kiosk replacement
is that the software upgrade only or do
you get you
sorry and which one sorry which point
5.1
oh sorry at the back yeah
the kiosk yeah they get an upgrade of
the software
has the whole kiosk replaced
so the library kiosk replacement is the
full thing
so the the old the old hardware frame
internals everything is gone it's
replaced so the screen becomes five
inches bigger
and the screen's also a lot more
responsive to the the touch
technology as opposed to what what it
was four years ago
um six years ago when it came in we're
getting a lot of older people finding it
quite difficult to work those screens
that's some of the feedback so so yes
that would be a full
wholesale replacement of each thing in
terms of priority
um is that more important than shelving
or
you would like everything you've
itemised obviously if we talk about
priorities uh what runs the ship
and what adds on to the ship so the
kiosks are an integral part of library
service now it's it's a bit like saying
we will go back to not using calculators
or
or not having um computers um either you
know evolution of services and
service models so if i'm really honest
uh kiosks are just a standard
library item that should be on a renewal
cycle by doing a full scale replacement
now
it future proves us for the next six
years
we could do an internal software upgrade
in six years or we could be looking
at not having as many kiosks
and using the handheld technology as it
evolves
i can't future guys no library in new
zealand is doing the app service at the
moment but i
am over the developments overseas and
i'm confident in that sort of five to
ten years seven to ten year window
that's where we'll be
as population grows we will need more
kiosks
so i would uh i would like to say
that in that sort of five to 10 10 year
window we would not be buying more
kiosks but we would be enabling the
handheld devices that most of us carry
to do some of that work in conjunction
with great customer service to enable
people to feel confident
um i would say my most important uh
thing in here is fines free the fact
that we have close to a thousand
children
under 18 unable to use their library
card or any electronic resources in
a district like ourses
that i'll just leave that there
we are one of the few library services
in new zealand that find our young
people
we are most library services many
library services
are investigating fine free for all
people
because they realize that those who need
libraries the most cannot afford any
debt
to many of us with our privilege four
dollars might not be a barrier
but for for a lot of people it is and
when i was talking to one of my staff
um i asked for her
you know for her thoughts on overdue
fines and she'd just had a mum coming
and this story
um to me would definitely make fine free
our priority we're going to be able to
make
additional shelving needs met with some
of the nzlpp funding so one third of
that
council approved last year some shelving
additional shelving so that's phase one
nzlpp is bringing to life phase two
economies of scale means we'll get more
if we do it all at once
but the fine free for me
is the most important the mother who
came in
said that she joined the library a few
years earlier when her two oldest
children were very young
at the time she was a single mum life
was very difficult and chaotic
she loved coming to the library with her
babies and reading them stories but
they had lost some books they had to
move frequently
and she didn't have the confidence or
the words
to come in and talk to library staff and
the overdue fines grew
the easiest thing for her was to stop
coming to the library and avoid the
situation and the debt fast forward five
years this young woman had come
had remarried and there was a new baby
and the family had a steady income
stream and a permanent home but they
still couldn't visit the library because
they owed money it was difficult and
embarrassing
and embarrassing is the thing that we
hear most i was on a national hui last
week was
representing public libraries of new
zealand
and the
non-judgmental space that libraries
offer
was recognized by internet new zealand
and the 43 other participants
at the hawaii the family would love to
be able to access more books for their
children
and their children are coming home from
school talking about the library and
being told they need a library card
but now what do they do finally this
woman came into the library she
approached jenny kirkwood at the desk
and explained that she wanted to join
the library but there's a problem
she started to chat with jenny and
before long jenny had met the whole
family and sorted out the money issues
and everyone had a new library card and
could access the new books and online
resources
jenny coached her to talk about problems
in the future with her library card so
this situation does not come up again
jenny said that children love books and
as a librarian i never want to be the
person who comes between a child and a
book
she said that children should not be
singled out from the rest
of their classmates when they cannot
have a library card
so that was that was very very powerful
to receive
so that's my priority
right i'll take any questions
no questions thank you
are you questioning or moving well i was
questioning right now
okay um these smart shelves is are if i
do
they they look pretty special so
they they are they are special but they
are becoming business as usual
so i should have brought you a list of
all the libraries across new public
libraries that are doing this and we're
not just talking the auckland in
christchurch
we're talking small they are the most
space efficient time efficient way of
processing library books nothing's
perfect we're not going to get a hundred
percent return on them
like perfect but we don't get that with
people either
they look really interesting thank you
so
much from the chair yeah hang on a
minute
i've got to get back to where i'm
supposed to be
right i'll move from a to e and
just a recommendation and i would just
like to say thank you very much paula
once again
a very interesting um
me report you've got done for us and
you're doing a marvelous job and really
appreciate
everything you and your staff do it's
it's really commendable
thank you
very briefly support the report uh also
um support consideration of your request
in the
long term plan i think it's important
that we keep place now
in our libraries noting the issues you
raised around the weight of
um shelving as well just went to your
library volunteers function last night
your comments is
such a great spirit there uh and it's
been a difficult year
and your team have certainly really
stepped up certainly through the
um covert period with the issuing of
books etc i think
um really excelled yourselves there so
that um we'll look at york and
your um requests uh in terms of the ltp
i'm i'm very sympathetic to the case you
put of the
family and barriers there shouldn't be
barriers to learning and people
accessing in our community
it's really important i know you're
doing work with karanga mai as well
went to their prize giving last week and
they came up and spoke to me
specifically about
the work that you're doing and they
appreciate trying to remove those
barriers for those
young parents being able to access book
books and learning in our community so
thank you for all that you do really
appreciate it paul thanks
thanks mr chairman i just wondered um
the fine free
proposal and clause 5.1.5
does that have to be part of the ltp or
can that be addressed
sooner than that should be part of the
ltp all of these matters will be subject
to further
ltp consideration later in january
right does the librarian have a
discretion over
imposing fines
i'm really the wrong person to ask right
i'll withdraw that question
against kerry thank you paula many
thanks thanks for all your support
um with the committee's approval i'm
going to change the order slightly
and bring 6.9 up next so the pegasus
ladies can get to go home before
midnight so matt can you come
they're not matt grant
so we're going to 6.9
yes thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen
also just to the committee thank you as
well for the reports that we've put up
today obviously there's quite a lot of
reading there
but this is i guess the end of a lot of
work that we've been doing
especially around kind of looking at
some of the community facility
and sports facility stuff that we've got
going on within community and recreation
so really important that we have
um some decisions on these and also give
you a bit of a briefing before
the ltp next january um also just want
to point out to
um shona and the wooden shift and
community board and also to the pegasus
residents group the triple r's
um obviously they've been quite
tenacious and actually i i believe
that's a polite phrase
um and actually kind of getting us to
where we've got to with
certainly half of this report in regards
to pegasus
so as with my predecessors i'll take the
report as read
i realize there's quite a few things in
there in terms of what you'll be wanting
to
get into and around asking questions a
couple of the things that are really
important
the pegasus residents group have just
asked that i point out that the
land in question obviously as richard
had said
was actually 17 more two key in terms of
one of the preferences that
both the group and also richard had
recommended within the report
that's the area of land that's basically
at the end of the bridge and on the
lake frontage richard felt that that was
actually a really important piece of
land from
uh pegasus perspective because it could
be opened up on to
the lake should we be in a position
where the lake is
as clean as one of matt's pools and that
people are actually able to use
it and and interact with it um
[Music]
it's also worth pointing out as well
it's probably not the entire parcel of
land
so whilst we've got 1.8 million dollars
in there it's really an up to figure
um the reality is that without land
negotiations at this point in time we're
trying to cover how much we believe we
might
need in order to go through that process
we're anticipating it'll probably take
around about a year to go through the
land purchase
um and that's purely because of the fact
that there's some uh anomalies there
with the fact that it's one big title at
this point in time
we're trying to tie the as you'll see in
one of the recommendations they were
trying to tie the youth project into it
which is excuse me um is currently
airmarked as a skate park
noting that the board are quite keen for
it to potentially be something else
i just have to say that
so look there's there's the potential to
kind of bring that into into play as
well
in terms of ravenswood uh at this point
in time we're really trying to indicate
that
from the report that richards put up we
believe that there's going to be a need
there in the future
now he's put a few options within the
draft report and
as we say it is a draft report so
there's a bit of discussion that we need
to have with him
but this is really to give a
pre-indication before the council
meeting in
late january around the ltp as to some
of the thinking that we've had and that
he's had in there as well
we obviously have a few of the level of
service triggers uh coming into play
especially around the likes of community
facility
and ravenswood and then also in terms of
library services within ravenswood as
well
um we
have options i guess within the area and
we're not going to know as much
today as what we will in the future so
really the idea is to try and identify
some budget so that we might be able to
purchase land at a point in time when
the community's growing a bit more and
we understand
more of what it is that we might be
looking at at this point in time with
ravenswood it's really an unknown
um we're trying to preempt the fact that
we know that we're probably going to
need some form of service there in the
future
that's why that budget's been put in
there to
explore the purchase of land there
noting that richard had also suggested
that there might be opportunities to
either utilise some space at the wooden
community centre
or for a library type service or
actually look at
wooden recreation reserve itself or even
gladstone park
none of those have been explored at this
point in time
but that's why staff have gone with the
recommendation of actually purchasing
land within ravenswood
um because we believe that that would
serve us where the key activity center
is and where the community is
as well um so that's why that's in there
a lot of talking points there so i'm
mindful of not
just me reading the report out but i'll
open the floor up for questions
can you just explain the process of this
report because it says
considers what does considers mean and
also note that in my report it's got the
same
it's got a b and e at the same point
they're actually doubled
it's asking for one point eight yes
twice so so sorry once one's for because
this one's for ravenswood ones with
pegasus one's through evansville
okay cool sorry just trying to figure
that one out yeah and so sorry the
reason that we've used the word
considers is because this committee
is basically stating to council that it
considers the inclusion of these budgets
within the ltp
so what i'm asking is when you say
considers now without the whole council
being part of this budget process
um it will go to our budget meetings in
january and at that point we get the
chance to decide whether it's in or
out and the financial ramifications
um
uh thank you for the report grant and
and i think um
through kershaw's questioning is exactly
right that this is just a recommendation
through to the ltp for council's
consideration
and ultimately um whether the council
considers it or not it'll be considered
in the wider
context but i personally feel that at
the very least we should be considering
land purchase and both
or sitting aside land or having the
opportunity for land in both pegasus and
ravenswood
to future proof opportunities for the
council i'm not going to express a view
about buildings at this particular
point in time nor libraries because
there are things that
we do need to consider in the wider
context but it's important
when we're considering the 10-year plan
that these items do go forward and are
considered and that the timings
dates etc we will need to debate further
um as part of that but as a holding
position i think this makes a lot of
sense
i'm not going to be able to be here for
i'm going to present some awards
um but i'm not going to be able to hear
for the theft and one but i similarly
support that report
because that community has worked hard
it's fundraised
it's got to a point now where it's
identified a facility
and i think it's timely that we as a
council do consider a contribution
towards that and there's a range of
conditions around that but
i think if we that we'd be remiss not to
be considering
parcels of land at the very least for
future provisioning
because it's been identified that we do
need to make sure that we have
facilities of some sort
there in the future so securing parcels
of land very least
that's where i'll be on the signaling
where my support would like coming into
the ltp
thank you so i will actually just go
back to the recommendation
and and make sure that as it is up to
1.8 million um and really
i'm i'm really supportive of both areas
being
uh put into this um recommendation
because they'll they will be all both of
them will be developing
quite substantially and um
that'll do me thinking
just speaking to the report i don't have
a vote on this committee but i would
still
if i had i would have put it forward
because i do think it's a very important
area that we need to discuss
i'm just very very cautious about
over-promising and under-delivering
we're going to have a very very tight
budget in the next two to three years
with all the effects that
covered and has had on our economy so
i want to reiterate that this is a
consider
and it's going to be putting everything
on the board and then we're going to see
the financial ramifications for the
rating
particularly for the next three years um
pegasus has
been hard done by in my view i've lived
in wood end
pegasus should have had more facilities
considering the level of population
the area of wood end including northwood
in which is known as ravenswood
and pegasus is going to be the third
biggest area in our district
and it deserves some good servicing but
the question is when
and i'm of a mind with um dan where i
actually agree which is the land that we
need to make sure that we've got
so that we can make sure for the future
but whether we're going to have the
funding to be able to build this in the
short term
i'm still not clear until i see the
financials in january
thank you some of the points i was going
to make has been
made by council of barnet
i very much believe in land banking with
cold stream we wouldn't be able to do
what we're doing now
if we hadn't had the vision years ago to
bank
some some land it got some flack in the
community when we purchased
that large area of land quite rightly
questions were asked
and it and it went through i'll give a
heads up now that as far as
these items are concerned i'll be
arguing for them
in our january meeting bearing in mind
that they will then go out
for consultation um no other point i
believe in land banking for the
for the future i had always snapped mr
cleary about a month six weeks ago some
of you recall
i never looked just at today i'm always
looking for tomorrow
in try to have a 50-year vision
on decisions such as such as these
i'll put that then all those in paper
say all right against carrie
thank you i'll you can go home now
thanks um thanks grant
uh good afternoon so uh the purpose of
my report is to update the community and
recreation committee
on the planning and delivery of two key
works uh the district aquatic strategy
and the updated aquatic asset management
and capital replacement scheduling
ahead of long-term plan deliberations
i'll be happy to take the report as read
but wish to highlight a couple of key
points
the district aquatic strategy was
developed to assess our
current operation and inform our
long-term planning
input was sought from key stakeholders
staff and elected officials
and fed into the process along with
current industry trends
local demographic projections
projections and councils growth
modelling
the resulting document highlights a
number of opportunities to maximize our
operation
with our current network and defined and
defines the community need for further
development
in the form of site expansion and new
site development
where the work falls within current
budgets staff have already begun to
explore and implement these works
to ensure we're able to continue to meet
the community demand for services in
space
within the next 10 years the strategy
recommends a number of works including
investigations
expansion at kaiapoi and construction of
a new facility in the northeast
the recommendations for these works are
based on community demand
projected growth and district
demographic stats
however considering the current economic
environment council's other project
commitments
and the community's ability to afford
such a such
development staff recommendation is to
put push
the majority of these works out beyond
the current long-term plan period
except for the issue of purchase of land
and investigation into the development
in kyboy
as highlighted by many of the speakers
earlier
it is important that the purchase of the
land goes ahead if possible
as further delay will only result in
increased cost to council
a smaller land package or the only land
available being in
less desirable locations while delaying
the other recommendations from the
strategy will likely see demand outstrip
supply
considerate management and operation of
sites would ensure we are able to best
maximise their use
and if the economic outlook was to
improve there is potential for these
works to be brought forward
finally an increase in unplanned
unplanned maintenance issues over recent
years prompted further investigation
into aquatics asset management and
capital renewals program
a survey was conducted completing a full
asset identification
condition assessment process to a
component level across our four sites
staff compared historic maintenance cost
and useful life data
with the original operation and
maintenance manuals and recent
contractor quotes to compile a more
accurate picture
of the aquatic plant systems the
recreation budget can
currently consist of 579 000 for plant
maintenance
and capital renewals over the next
10-year period period
however this work has identified the
need to increase that by a further 1.66
million
for an overall budget of 2.25 million
over the next 10 year period
just to maintain the currently levels of
service
while this work does require commitment
of additional budget
this work will be loan funded decreasing
the rating requirement
and ensuring that if future condition
assessments of the equipment do not
require replacement
this work can be deferred with no impact
happy to take questions
how much have we spent on the coyote
heat pump
uh yes so that was 200 and
no that wasn't the car overall overall
it's been 220 in the last about
three years spent on heat pumps and
maintenance and
compressors and when i read this report
i struggle with this this is a need
um and that's why i asked the question
how much have we spent
when why haven't why are we replacing
that that is part of this this plan
is it yeah includes the the replacement
of the
the kaiapoi heat pump and other other
similar units
oh maybe it was cheating
i said it earlier and i'll say it again
listen horrendously important reports of
today's
today's meeting and um
quite quite frankly uh we're in for a
really challenging time come
end of january we gave staff an
indication of where we'd
like rates to be looking uh going out
because
i just can't say we're going to achieve
that because this is another
really important report indicating
investment
so nothing more to say
just just to provide you some assurance
we're still working hard to try and get
a
rate picture that is one that you could
support to the community first two years
starting with a three although a high
three probably in
later years early fours are probably
what we are
looking to bring to you in january and
we'll be explicit in the briefing about
what's
in those numbers and what's out but at
the moment the numbers that you've got
here are in the
in the profile the ones that we're
talking about today sit in the
in the profile that we'll be bringing to
you so
we are working hard to get you a number
that
you can live with which deals with these
acknowledges these important issues
thanks jim yeah and remember that like
the previous item there's lots of
considers in here so
it's very much it considers rather than
a commitment um as when we get to the
ltp
no no robbie writer replied i'll put
those it for that to report then for
adoption all those in favor say aye
against carrie thank you we are up to
6.6 symmetries
lindley
yep
good afternoon um this report
um is brought to you seeking your
approval of the draft
cemetery policy the updates have been
done since the council briefing
last week and we would also like you to
appoint three
councillors to sit on our hearing panel
early next year
i think march the week of march the
third
has been that she drilled in but i can
confirm that
i will take the report has been read
i think the policy won't be a stranger
to you and
the certainly we did address the
concerns that council had last week in
updating this policy before it came to
you today
mr mira i called you um
i would like to be part of that panel
pass nothing nothing to add robbie well
that's pretty simple will i move i'll
move that report for
adoption all those in favor say oh
against
carrie
for the last hour
ladies and gentlemen uh grant mccloud
again um
to my right is rhino lachlan who
handles a lot of the capital and
operational planning within the green
space team as well
so i've just got ryan here because
obviously there might be a few questions
just around how some of the budgets are
going to be working
just worth noting here within the sports
facilities plan update
uh i'll take the report as read
richard's given us an outline at the
start of the meeting um
one of the things that i just wanted to
discuss was the fact that the main
change here is
um really around the timings of the
budget that we're looking at
one of the good news items here is that
within the first three years we're
actually looking at a reduction
of capital cost which
is actually a reflection of a lot of the
work that's happened to date over the
last three years
so you may recall in the last ltp
quite a significant amount of money was
actually set aside for sports facilities
that covered a lot of things such as the
dudley lights
improvements to some of our
turfs plus also we did
went in with the kaiapoi high school as
well and did some work with them too
so we've actually achieved a lot of the
things that we set out to achieve and
the biggest one being main power stadium
as well
which came out of that that report for
for need too
so look you'll see there that the new
revised budget is looking at
within the first three years just the
265 000
um we'd also note that out in years
8 and 10 of the ltp we're looking at a
significant increase and really that's
around the artificial turf renewals and
replacements
um and that's purely the indicated
figures that we believe will need
at that point in time for that sort of
technology
that's because in essence we need to be
uplifting
not only the top surface of that but
then also the shock pads underneath as
well
because they'll be reaching the end of
their of their life
um and this was one of the points that
robbie was making as well we normally
get this
paid back in two hours via hockey and
football
unfortunately at this point in time
football haven't been paying those bills
because they simply don't have the
financial means to actually pay for the
turf
as much as they're using it so like i'll
take it as red
i'm aware that there's possibly a few
questions on this one so i'll
hand it over
oh i have got yes sorry yeah
just looking through the
1.7 where um
for the indoor court facility i just see
that
netball are wanting to look at using it
as well
and also gymnastics so
are those both the plates and everything
going to go in beforehand
for both of those
uh yeah so it actually states there that
um the the progress update is that those
plates will be inserted
right yeah so we'll get that in our next
briefing
i potentially it depends once they're
actually installed they
might just be ordered at this point in
time for for installation
i'd have to check with craig around
exactly where that's going thank you
just that was just a query
thank you very much for this in-depth
report it's helping us to understand
exactly what is required and needed um
and just looking at
how you've budgeted each each item over
the next
three you know 10 years
it's just making us appreciate just the
amount of money that has to go into
these facilities to to keep them
trucking along
so i thank you for that
whoops yes thank you it starts off with
good news and um
the news gets worse as we get to the end
of the period the 10-year period
um just to echo what robbie said i
i would like to see some consideration
given
to kendall park and what we can do with
the artificial turf there
um it's not fair on other users who are
paying me away if we have someone who
isn't
so i'd like that given some
consideration um
but apart from that nothing else
again i'm just camping out here i
believe
yep um so look this is in regards to our
community facilities you'll be aware
that at this point in time we have an
annual renewal program of around about
fifty thousand dollars
um what we're in essence looking at here
is that simon and ish
um with the help of ryan as well over
the last uh 12 months i've actually been
looking at an
asset data capture for
all of the facilities that we've got to
determine the kind of work that we need
over the next
10 year period the reality is is that
we've got a lot more compliance measures
that we have to meet a lot more health
and safety a lot more fire regulations
um you'll note that with cust as soon as
we went in there we actually triggered a
whole lot of things that we had to
that we had to do to bring the building
up to code and that kind of
i guess forced our hand in terms of how
much budget we had to attribute through
to
the work that we were doing there this
is really a reflection of that the
community facilities
have actually done really well but gone
are the days that we can get community
groups to actually manage a lot of these
for us and do the work that's required
and now we have to ensure that we're
actually meeting quite a lot of building
warranty fitness
recommendations that we're doing the
compliance work that's required
so hence that we're actually looking at
an increased budget for this
now ryan is here and he's going to
just very briefly articulate how the
depreciation fund works
in that regard
thanks grant um so as noted in the
report the funding for the renewals
program
comes from the community facilities
depreciation fund this has already been
calculated in the rates
so the amount that we're increasing it
by is not
the total amount that we're taking
annually that will build up
um we've built up over the years to
renew the entire building
once we get to that point this is to do
with the interior
fixtures and fittings lots of heat pumps
and other assets
yes and you'll note that in year one
we've left it um
half of what we've suggested for year
two and three the reason being that we
wanted to have a lot of year within the
first year of the ltp just to give us a
little bit more
uh room to kind of get the market in
order in terms of delivering what it is
that we need but also to reflect the
fact that we're going from 50k a year
up to 150 so we didn't want to make that
jump to 300 immediately
happy to take questions
um
you got me again
yeah yeah um so this is the sefton
community hall
um councillors will
probably be aware of the fact that we've
had quite a lot of meetings with the
sifton community and shifting community
hall
committee actually looking at what their
options are going forward
um they've been doing a lot of planning
with the committee with the community
over the last few years
this is a non-council owned facility
that sits on
private land that the trust owned so
with the help of
councillor redmond they've actually been
going through
and doing quite a lot of work to both
look at the
community library that they have there
but also this bit of land as well to
identify what the best
the best option is for them to go
forward again they
worked through rsl consultants and did a
feasibility study
that came up with two options for them
that they seriously considered one was
to remain on the site that they're on
and repair the building
the other one which has now become their
preferred option at their last
meeting is to move up to
shift and domain in essence what they
would then be doing
is combining the pavilion
facility within a new facility that's
purpose built
on the domain what we're suggesting here
is that we actually include a grant
to that that really is kind of seed
money if you like because it allows them
to go out to other funders they've got
a quantum of money that they can access
and
they're probably still needing to raise
somewhere in the region of around about
five to six hundred thousand dollars
um they've got around about three
hundred thousand available to them
um with this grant here that would
actually encourage other funders on
board
and we could make sure that this is much
like the tennis one was
that they've got to get the other
funding before they can secure this one
from us
happy to take questions on that one
he's thinking the old library
are they able to hopefully sell that
the land or what yeah and i fell i don't
know if you want to add anything to that
but the last conversation that we had i
believe that they had been given the
rights to do that
through the or they hadn't because it's
been a struggle for them to
to get to the end to this part
can i just make a comment here i um
i support and support what we're doing
here i just flag a risk
around this project and that
what is signaled as the average
cost and the exclusions here
is quite a gap from what we've just
you've endorsed being a provision for
inclusion for a similar size facility
elsewhere at a significantly different
quantum
and there's a number of exclusions here
so
i hope like heck that they are able to
secure funding and then get a project
together
for that quantum if they can't
then there's a there's a there's a
stellar risk profile around it
um the square meter right here is
significantly lower than the square root
of the square meter right we're
applying elsewhere and
done by the same consultant i would add
so
something's one of them's not quite
right or there's a significant level of
service different so i just
highlight that there's still some risk
around
the financial envelope required will be
supporting a community group to do the
best
they can on which is
a good a good proposal
if if i made him the um the difference
would be
a tremendous amount of level of service
so with the
um ravenswood
proposal really what they've kind of
suggested there is because there would
be library services as
it's at a much higher level of service
than what we could possibly
see here but again that is a massive
risk in terms of
it is a huge difference in cost and
because of the exclusions there as well
it very much will have a lot of risk
involved there
um regardless of not building to the
same level of service as a library
there are still some question marks
around there until they have a detailed
design
um and we actually know exactly what
that would be tended for
i i'd note that but i even you know and
i don't want to debate it with you
across
across the table but at pegasus we're
talking 2.7 million for
380 squares which isn't a library
versus one point three or four here for
a similar size
facility and so there is there
there there i'm just signaling there's a
there's
some further work yet to be done to
finalize the cost estimates
um i'm very supportive of
of this recommendation i hear the
words of warning about risk and costings
um this group they're a good bunch that
have been working very hard themselves
for probably at least five years to try
and
make some progress i had an email from
the library
uh section shall we say yesterday
and they're getting a wee bit frustrated
that it has been five years and they
still haven't been able to sell the
library
and use those funds towards the hall
i can say that the court
has appointed living people
as trustees for the library rather than
long deceased people who haven't been
here for a hundred odd years
um so that was the first step
helmor stewart almost ready to file an
application they say it will be filed by
the end of january
with the court that the library can be
sold
in the proceeds in terms of the trust
applied towards a new community hall
so um that'll probably be in the
hopefully in the first
part of next year that will be heard so
i've no idea what the library is worth
they were talking 100
000 plus so that will be money to go
towards the project
a 1-1 would have actually been for the
hall
to be rebuilt where it is with the
assistance of the ministry of education
but that avenues being flogged to death
and
there was no traction with the ministry
so
the community end up with a good result
but the school community
end up with a less ideal result than
could have otherwise
been achieved but i think this grant of
200 000
will go a long way towards helping the
group they'll have the sale of the
existing
building and site sale of the library
they've got their insurance
proceeds plus 200 from us
and fingers crossed that we may get a
building in the domain
so um i just think these people are to
be congratulated for their
persistence and perseverance and i'm
more than happy to help
item item seven thanks jim item seven is
now withdrawn because the
kaiapoi community board did not um
go ahead with the um proposal for the
for the
stock bank steps for financial fiscal
reasons
we don't we don't need to receive that
then at all do it just comes off the
agenda
because it went to i can't remember
whether the recommendation went to
council as opposed to community and
recreation
we have still have to receive it okay
that we receive the item
is that what we need to do when the all
those in favor say aye against carrie
okay right correspondence um
we have and from uh
from i know nothing about that you know
what that in
correspondence was we just received it
yep it's uh
from uh around your early records saying
that they're
appreciative of the grant which has
enabled them to continue
an operation thank you i'll move from
the chair we receive that information
secondary wendy all those in favor say
all right
it's carried thank you portfolio updates
go away paul williams i'm not talking to
you
you want to read that read robbie's
report
so robbie's got a number of bullet
points here i will try and read as
rapidly as i can um
uh christmas trees put up in rangiora
and kaiapoi
the wrapping uh kayak we had to be taken
down due to wind damage so we're looking
for it an alternative for next year
flags installed in oxford flags will be
going up in rangiora
and kaiapoi in the new year plus a new
flag track system
which makes it easier to change the
flags
and much more cost effective tree
planting in the rangiora airfield access
road trees supplied by ecan
and 1200 were planted with help from
volunteers from the air
field norman kirk changing rooms final
works have been completed and expected
diamond softball diamonds to be opened
early in the new year with thanks for
the work for the regeneration team
currently
have more enquiries for the marina and
casual
user has birthed there at the moment
ongoing discussions re
pile moorings and pot and mooring owners
seek being planned for the installation
at arlington shopping complex before
christmas memorial
milton memorial park is out for
consultation at the moment
we'll be bringing an updated plan to the
board in the new year
stand of lombardy poplars have been
removed from the ashley campground
they posed a health and safety risk so
staff worked with the advisory group and
got a contract to remove
them safely kai poi bmx track
maintenance due to be completed this
week
first as the final treatment for the
track has long
been open first this is the first
treatment the track has
since opening is being well used so the
work is being managed
at a quieter time of the week and prior
to the school holidays
pearson park pavilion damage storage
door being replaced
has been a successful event with a
variety of events occurring across parks
network no incidents to report other
than a few complaints following
fireworks
but this has been worked through with pa
um work on mandeville and tara cartney
toilets are continuing expected to be
completed by christmas hiranui reserve
development is nearing completion we'll
be open to the
public by christmas this includes a
small sports goal planting and some
balance
items owen stalker park design has been
finalized expected to go to tender in
january 21
community and community board were very
happy with the concept plan so looking
forward to it being completed
renewal of playground surfacing and
equipment are continuing
low burn irrigation progress project is
progressing with the club club have
proposed a solution are looking to
lead the works initial design is
underway on good street redevelopment
and workshop
was held with the community board on the
9th of december at its meeting
final work was completed on the kaiapoi
stop
bank artwork project decking and seats
installed around the ship's
crane and finally the cuss community
center shovel ready project painting has
been completed and designed is currently
in progress for the roading aspect
for this government funding expected to
go to this 10
tender in december thank you thank you
well done
speed reader
your portfolio yeah um
sorry um first of all we just like to
talk about the waiver fees we had a
committee that
looked at the waiver fees but um we seem
to be having so many coming through
wanting the their fees completely waived
again so we're going to have to have a
in the new year have a good serious look
at how we work
this a bit better than what it does
because it's certainly not working the
way that we had hoped
um age friendly group well you've had
your information regarding that
and just work in progress there we just
need to be moving
on with it stadium y macarena we had a
meeting last
um in november and
um i don't think we're not won't be
having another one about
february but uh you would have got in
the hopefully
got through your emails some updated
photos from
did you get that from here which just
showing how quickly it's moving on which
is
very pleasing indeed um ashy gorge
advisory board
having a tremendous success with their
um
tracks that they have that the voluntary
done themselves which is a real credit
they haven't asked for
any help from anybody and
they're just wanting to to go right up
over the top and
um i think it's about a 5k walk or
something like that i'm just not too
sure now
but they've just got a few little issues
that they've got a bit of private land
that they've got to have
which is stock land that they need
permission to go and also there's a
an a um road there too that just just
one of those unformed roads so
they just have work to do on that one
which is frustrating them a bit but
it'll happen pensioner housing that's
going well they've got um
quite a lot of work's been done on them
and the pensioners seem to be pretty
happy with that
um going to a mandeville sports club
tonight they're going to launch their
strategy plan to the
the team so that's uh really good tool
that you
so and the cuss community board um
just want to know not sorry the cast
community
hall whatever they want to call
themselves
and wanting to know why they are a
neighborhood they're classed as a
neighborhood reserve that's not quite
the hall is not quite fitting with what
they felt it should be
that was just passed on from another
member thank you
and the other thing that i just really
wanted to say was also was
you know i did mention about eve on
palmer um
she has done tremendous work for age
friendly
and for um the
road um drivers senior
senior driving things and um
i'm just really sorry that she's unable
to
continue on with that through a serious
illness such as head
thank you
my question is when are we going to be
able to have that
that giraffe shifted into
february well he's he's offered it
probably about 18 months ago now and
nothing's been done and it's
free of charge he's going to install it
himself so
please